as my mother has three, four weeks using the rife machine with her cancer protocol.
In that time, she's begun experiencing daily diarrhea. Could this be for the body's
way of detoxifying? No changes in supplement or diet. What should she do to alleviate this?
So can the rife machine using cancer programming, cancer frequencies cause diarrhea?
Well, anything's possible with any physiological change to your body. So yes, I'd say that is
possible. So it could be her body detoxifying. I would start by putting the bulb a little bit farther
away from her. I don't know if she's using. First of all, I don't know who asked this question. So
if your mom is a member of ours, a patient's ours, then we should probably have a discussion
what else she's taking and what else she's doing. So I'm not sure who was that asked this question.
But that should be the first thing. We want to get some more data. If it is truly the rife
and using cancer frequencies and it's causing diarrhea or constipation or any other physiological change,
then doing either moving the bulb away a little bit farther away from your body so you're not
getting such direct frequency content contact. Looking at other things in your diet, even though
diet and supplements weren't changed, your physiology might be working better in things that you were
doing before that were causing and decreased gut motility. Maybe you need to back off on. So you
want to look at the big picture with anything like this and not just, you know, from a perspective of
is it the rife? So if your mom is down a patient of ours and she bought a rife somewhere else and
she's doing cancer frequencies, then do it a case review with me and we can discuss some of those
things. Why do you need more?